from living in a housing project to
being worth over 500 million dollars
this is a success story of jay-z hi I'm
Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I also
believe that the fastest way to
accomplish any goal is to model the
success of somebody who's already
accomplished it so today we're going to
learn from rapper turned entrepreneur
jay-z and the top three lessons that you
can learn from his success born Charen
carter he grew up in a housing project
in Brooklyn he was raised with his three
siblings by his mother after his father
abandoned them he loved music and used
to wake up his siblings by banging out
beats on the kitchen table she bought
him a boombox for his birthday and he
used it to freestyle and write lyrics he
was known as jazzy in his neighborhood a
name that eventually developed into
jay-z he started his singing career
under a mentor fellow rapper jazz oh he
was featured on several of jazz O's
early records and was involved in
several rap battles with LL Cool J in
the early 90s today he is worth over
five hundred million dollars is one of
the most successful hip-hop artists of
all time
and continues to invest in and build
businesses to expand his wealth and
influence here are the top three lessons
that you can learn from jay-z's success
number one bet on yourself when jay-z
was getting started no major label
wanted to give him a record deal rock
music was too unproven and jay-z wasn't
a well-known artist instead of giving up
he bet on himself and partnered with
Damon Dame Dash and Kareem Biggs Burk to
start his own independent label in 1995
Rockefeller Records he was the only
artist signed to the label and he
started by selling his CDs out of his
car even his mentor jaz-o refused to
sign with a new label he continued to
hustle and believe in himself and
eventually signed a distribution deal
with Priority Records jay-z's first
album reasonable doubt reached number 23
on the Billboard 200 and would later be
included in Rolling Stones 500 greatest
albums of all time before anyone else
will believe in you you need to believe
first bet on yourself number two create
alliances jay-z never operated alone and
always formed a line
is to help him achieve his goals
Rockefeller Records would start it with
his friends - and Burke
his first album reasonable doubt used
beats from acclaimed producers DJ
premier and super DJ Clark Kent as well
as an appearance by the notorious b.i.g
future albums would be collaborations
with Sean Puff Daddy combs Timbaland
Kanye West Eminem Beyonce Lenny Kravitz
Linkin Park and others he continues to
use his strategy today as he creates a
title music streaming service with some
of the top names in the music community
don't try to do everything yourself find
people who believe in your mission and
can contribute to it to help you move it
forward create alliances number three
expand your base jay-z didn't want to
just be a rapper he wanted to be an
entrepreneur and expand his base beyond
his music he co-founded the urban
clothing brand Rocawear with Damon Dash
as an extension of his brand he later
sold the rights to the Rocawear brand
for two hundred and four million dollars
but retains his ownership in the
business and continues to help run it he
co-owns a 40/40 club an upscale sports
bar with locations in New York Atlantic
City Chicago and plans for Tokyo and
Singapore he's invested in the
entrepreneurial ventures sports teams in
real estate he started his own sports
agency Roc Nation sports and acquired
Armand de Brignac champagne he is now
launched title a subscription-based
music streaming service your business
venture should be reflection of who you
are and where your interests lie don't
box yourself in expand your base my
advice is do things that are true to you
you know you know most things that I'm
involved with are extension of being
creative you know Rockaway is a clothing
company you know it's part of who you
are and hip-hop is your attitude and
what you're trying to spread Express how
you dress I love sports growing up I
grew up in a household where sports was
on 24 you know seven so these are things
that are you know are comfortable for me
you know these are things that I like so
I would just say get involved in things
that you love and also have you know
have a standard for yourself and have
some sort of integrity and try to you
know find some sort of truth in what
you're doing
so remember bet on yourself create
alliances and expand your base and you
could be on your way to building a half
a billion dollar empire yourself and of
course believe thank you so much for
watching I'd love to hear what you have
to think of jay-z as an entrepreneur in
the comments below
also if you have a suggestion for who
you would like to see me profile next
leave a comment and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and the
newsletter thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon
you